Chris waters here with a gamespot news
update the developers of batman arkham
knight have confirmed that the game's
release date has been pushed till next
year Rocksteady Studios has realized
that in order to make a compelling
finale to the Arkham trilogy they need
more time Dex Ginn brand marketing
producer at Rocksteady Studios said
awesome takes time and totally awesome
takes a lot of time we have decided to
extend the development time of batman
arkham knight batman arkham knight is
only coming to pc xbox one and
playstation 4 apparently in order to
create a world to feel satisfying to
drive the Batmobile through they needed
to create a much larger space the Gotham
City and Arkham Knight will be five
times larger than the game world of
Arkham City guy Perkins marketing game
manager at Rocksteady Studios told
GameSpot we feel that we have an
absolutely awesome game in the works and
we want to make it as great as it
possibly can be and we just need more
time to do that we want to make sure
we're absolutely nailing it a hundred
percent as always for all the latest
gaming news stay tuned to gamespot com /
news